greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by Fuji Sports calm listen I love Fuji I
never give up on food that's all the
ghee I wear is Fuji if you're a big guy
and you want adorable ghee Fuji is the
way to go they have mats they got rash
guards they got shin guards they got
mouthpieces whatever you get need they
got Fuji Sports is there for you
also this podcast is brought to you by
one of my favorites my bookie listen
whether you're an expert or a rookie you
should be betting at my bookie if you're
the type of guy who likes the better
little and win a lot like playing
numbers on the roulette you can create a
huge parlay pick three teams to win and
if you hit all three you could turn 100
into 600 hours listen this weekend we
got UFC Cormier vs. Lewis the World
Series is done but you got the NBA
you got everything and it's all under
one roof with my bookie I recommend
these guys so do me a favor right now
log on to my bookie right now and don't
miss out on the last opportunity to
collect the industry's biggest bonus use
promo code Church and you'll get your
first deposit matched and a hundred
percent a hundred percent you understand
me that's promo code Church my bookie
you play you win you get paid
it's Tuesday the 30th Netflix day
degenerates and my main man Jerry Rocha
hello kick that [ __ ] muley I get
much out of Tuesday you're not awake
after that deal greetings you bad
[ __ ] thank you very much for
streaming [ __ ] degenerates if you
have and yeah you had whatever the [ __ ]
you did you know how we doing the uncle
Joey loves you no matter what it's up
it's ready I don't know what to tell you
anyway Jerry Roach is here direct from
Laredo [ __ ] Bamba Ville the original my
little brother Lisa I am stoned to the
gills I'm trying to make them
which man of the year I think you're
right though we just gotta rip those
hits on Twitch Oh me the most popular
channel you got Teddy's gang got a big
big J can't say I try to hit the bong
hits but you get one hits that like a
hat my lungs filled on fire I don't
worry about that that's all that means
the reason why I was thinking about you
lately Jerry's yeah because it's just so
weird how you there's a certain breed of
people and I've been here for 20 years
I've been doing this podcast for six but
Lee we've had to all types of guests
here you've been on a podcast before
yeah I dig you to death I loved
everything I loved that man yeah but
it's so weird that you're a grinder like
that lane to get rid of you yeah you
don't have to get the warrant oh yeah
get a bad case of chlamydia you're
always up to something
and I've known you since day one how
long were you in the game with me I've
been doing comedy maybe three years as
this year's little past el paso texas I
was middling for you it was one of my
first ever there they come in the first
week Bart ever gave me two middle and I
did I once I had 20 minutes man 25
minutes I sent him a VHS tape and I did
bugged him every day hey man you know
hear how I'm open of course my veils are
wide [ __ ] open but I would have it
always lie until this week I can't do it
but next you know I mean the comic book
plays I was at a bookstore working at a
bookstore in doubt in the music
department of a big-ass Barnes & Noble
in Dallas and yeah and I was just and
they were cool enough to wear hey I need
next week I got you was this eight maybe
ninety nine so where I was thinking yeah
I know this boy yeah I wrote you if the
20 years or 20 you had just done bass
ketball I believe I believe you had just
finished bass ketball
that was I believe I think that's about
that where it was does that prove that
bringer bells in private okay the first
time I went to El Paso
I am seed yeah I took a [ __ ] bus down
there
was 250 dollars yeah fourth of July
weekend I forget the two guys name so I
even more right and then I didn't hear
from him for a long time in the night
there yeah but I got booked through him
through an agency in New York City and
then I became friends with him because
he really trusted that dude in New York
not that I headlined the week you feed
up yet Bart was really he really he
really valued that dude in New York the
the agent in New York that guy Bart
would kind of throw he would throw bar
to wreck at Bart back oh yeah okay great
you know like he he was kind of silence
he really yeah he worked with that guy a
lot and I remember I yeah I think it was
my first time ever middling it was still
in the West Side room the second room in
the West Side the big the really big one
and yeah I remember I get there and
instant we're talking about Pink Floyd
the minute I walk in the door we bonded
over that I remember you went with me I
went ahead like Thursday I drove across
town to a comic book store to buy some
actions big here's week we go to the
Chinese buffet and we're gonna get I
went and bought like four action figures
at the cover you're breakin my balls
oh he didn't go in anyways he was in the
car I was real quick I got him and he
was just laughing as I'm walking with
Thor and Iron Man and then we went to
Burlington Coat Factory remember this
and we stalked the [ __ ] up on remember
when Outkast had a clothing plan the
rapper's they had like those velour
sweat suits all the rest of the weekend
Joey and I were just an outcast velour
crushed velvet that we were like [ __ ]
Jesus then in those days I was so big I
was starting to get big and the only
place I could buy clothes is in Texas
yeah cuz it dude yeah to X we gotta fall
we got two sons you know we're two x's
in Texas there's way bigger than the 2x
yes it is yes it is really weird when
you go to Texas and you buy
shirt is too excellent big ugly yeah
I've lost weight I'm gonna eat oh my god
it's weird
so I remember working there as an MC
yeah and then I did a lot of feature
work and I so like if this I give props
where props is due and that was a club
that I learned oh yeah I ripped that old
club with the game manager who I dearly
love John that's all what was his name
he was John I think you're right I mean
I loved him with everything I had like
whenever I would get the call to go down
at a feature because I had a
relationship I took I got all the
cancellations yeah and well yeah biggest
ballbusting z' I haven't gotten this
time which I'll tell the story now is
you know Bart would call me on Monday
afternoons and say you're going to I'll
pack can you come topaz so somebody
featured from New York and some
last-minute and in those days we you
were getting 550 for the week yeah okay
but the flight no matter when you
[ __ ] looked online was always 180 it
was always always 180 so that's a third
of your pay that's a third so you look
at that and you look at the Greyhound
bus and you got too hot 45 bucks
it was 29 25 back 120 Evan yeah and 35
for the Mexican bus that's gonna hell
where they put the Telemundo on yeah
grandma self-talk those buses are nicer
than the graveyard by the way like a
dope man they have places where you can
hang your shirt and laundry yeah get the
Sundays to watch this they get laundry
done on the bus
do you guys things they don't [ __ ]
around off the road cuz you know a lot
of those people are on a two three day
trip yes they're you know I mean a lot
of them are they're coming from deep in
Mexico and they're coming up and so
going back whatever and yeah that they
accommodate it's almost like a being on
it's like a fancy train except this is
one big butts yeah like so I've grabbed
came tight with El Paso yeah like I was
such a regular down there like anytime
he had a fallout he would call me last
minute yeah Joey I got this guy or if
somebody's agent was busting his balls
even we [ __ ] this guy yeah [ __ ] young
he would call me yeah
light him up like do your [ __ ]
nastiest material in front of him dude
he did that to me a cup that was the
best he didn't like he was a headliner
he would SiC the dogs on dogs I hate
your agent it was at that time it was a
guy from Romney pop and he was booking
room there were real features yeah great
comics but they were features sure but
they were booked up mother's headliners
because at that time I'll pass Oh was
Abbeville yeah so I was a [ __ ] be at
our feature yeah and I would like these
[ __ ] guys Christmas trees I steal
them with someone Saturday night this
poor guy had a ukulele out all I said
that's all we don't work with one
weekend we buried somebody why can't we
say me when I okay so we did Barry's
[ __ ] yeah didn't you and I would team up
on some way and just bury them ah yeah
because yeah and then was funnies when
you grew when you passed on when you
went on to headline I kind of took your
place as the fallout middle guy right
cuz I mean and of course I would drive
from Dallas ten hours I'll just do it I
would just get in the car is ready
yeah about tech is it's it's almost
halfway so it's almost the same Drive in
LA to El Paso Dallas Dell boom and yeah
like it but nine 10 hours until I that
was forget being in Houston and Pete
Pirelli come downstairs and he goes hey
man I just got a call like it was it was
Saturday yeah I was snorting coke like a
[ __ ]
yeah whatever my salary was was down in
the shed a sugar anyway and I would just
go to Texas like I would just tell Terry
like I'm gonna tack this like what I'm
coming back I have no right right well I
was in Houston I got a call to go to
some place and I agreed to go
I forget the comics name and I was so
coked up and I agreed to go I got a call
from the kid Monday he's like I am
pick up Tuesday night at 11:00 we're
gonna drive all night idle all night
we're gonna Midland maybe yeah probably
it was a nine-hour [ __ ] yeah that's
about right from Houston to Midlands
nine now and you're not eat that's not
even like that's like that's like you're
covering like not even half of the map
you know biggest in the country I think
Alaska technically cuz it but a [ __ ] is
all ice right so yeah like it land wise
it's right up there with Kelly it's
Texas California it's like there's even
California's like what seven eight hours
it's a little more to go from like if
you go like from the from the top that's
it that's a that's a haul but like I
mean Texas because it goes both ways all
right like so Houston to El Paso that's
a [ __ ] that's a trek and then from
the top of the Panhandle down to Laredos
and that's an ocular how far can use
don't El Paso god that's probably more
than Dallas I bet that might be you're
looking at maybe 10 12 hours she's just
Christ yeah 10 12 hours I still remember
Ralphie coming to visit me you know
Passover howdy and just I just that Club
was that corner Club yeah I don't know
about when he moved
ya know about what now whatever that
corner Club I got a knock in there like
I just had a knack so [ __ ] like I was
in there so much yeah but I just became
comfortable like I was one of the few
feature acts that killed on military
night dude those are yeah man's rough
yep Wednesday nights was military night
and I figured them out it was packed
packed bar up the corn festival [ __ ]
eyes [ __ ] I never saw anything like that
in my life
I remember you wouldn't let me drive
home the night the weekend we met I was
it was a Monday morning and I was gonna
I have like an hour drive back to Dallas
and I woke up at like noon and I'm
getting ready and I'm packing my [ __ ]
and you're like where the [ __ ] are you
going and I'm like no I gotta drive to
Dallas sit the [ __ ] down you're not
going anywhere and on vh1 it was the
behind the music Pink Floyd
going anyway he's gonna be here for two
more hours they're gonna we're watching
this and then you could like a believed
to be a supermarket the Reg the lion
something was at the edge of yeah yeah
I'm the condo yeah walk down the oh you
could walk that yeah and I was a fat
[ __ ] I used to in mind making the walk
move because the food I was real good
the homemade food the homemade Mexican
food there I can play Mexican food in
the supermarket push Fridays I always
made sure I got cooked up on Thursday
nights is Friday they had fresh Yucatan
fish soup right and it was like this
Mexican soup with everything included to
Vince's high balls and spying ads every
time you took a bite out of it you're
getting something yeah but the food the
soup was so good for you yeah you could
see this was real fish soup this was no
couple pieces of things right right
cream this was a Mexican style fish soup
I would get the big container of them
and they would have those packages with
those [ __ ] childhood thing yeah yeah
oh Jesus and they give you lemons the
poor in the soup last head give you like
five lines like yeah I then and I'd be
hungover as [ __ ] and I'd bring loved
that ball home and I drink half of it
straight I put the lines in there I
please Charlie everything and when at
the end it just be spines when we spit
them out there was every type of fish in
there God knows how did he write you
don't ask right right right
they had ceviche Jesus they had a bunch
of [ __ ] in the head yeah they had
Hardee's which at the time that was the
last time I have a Hardee's yeah because
I ate at one time than the second time
it tastes funny
put the bottle off and the meat was
skinned yeah it was human skin no it
wasn't yeah that Hardee's is mad the
people would just been a fire yeah and
they caught it was at the charcoal
burger because if the people had just
been first I looked at it you can see
the face that's so much when the
horseradish [ __ ] can
it tastes to me here Donna I was always
an Arby's guy that's our dream that's if
you remember the hobbies I'll pass on RV
there was Arby's the supermarket then
you made the right ahead turn up to help
that art that was on the west side and
it was next to a Radio Shack yeah man
yeah so I used to [ __ ] go to that
Radio Shack and I used to go that Arby's
and I was you broke bleep yeah you got
to live off drilling or making buck up
we yack a 180 goes to the plane ticket
yeah well they do know and don't say
that but the $30 bus
yeah no now I had become a regular he's
like I was telling you the story so I'm
sitting there with John Wesley mm-hmm
Ralphie man Jody having and I say to
them I'm taking I'm so embarrassed that
I had a rival right do it what time you
even throw pass on when I go I'm leaving
tonight you know like what time do you
need a ride to the airport I don't know
right down the station the guy I'm
working with so I picked me up with you
right right
I was too embarrassed to do it I feel it
man yeah [ __ ] you John Wesley you did
take it but I had to take a [ __ ]
Boston they'd Ralphie drove me down it
and Ralphie the [ __ ] there he is
around the corner sat there and watched
me get on the bus like no like going to
the bus tonight
like I waited out there like waving
either right five minutes and then he
went up the corner and waited on me and
they saw me going to the bus man so when
I got back he's like what time's your
flight get back today from my past or my
colleagues lunch time here's your
[ __ ] life you didn't see me did you
years you bust my balls you just forgot
about it
and you're always funny when you what
time you're playing commit because up I
saw was a great room to do one Saturday
yeah because I think that you could
still catch the bus yeah after the show
on set those buses went lay yeah there
was a 1 a.m. boss yeah
yeah that got you back here at 1:00 by
two o'clock next day yeah yeah there was
looks just sleep on the bus and you're
good man just crash on the bleep oh my
god I used to get [ __ ] up on those
buses yeah
that's yummy you go on those bus I
remember when I met you do you remember
how we met I walked I got to the condo
and you were just sunbathing like a
gangster and the flat the swimming pool
remember that you just sitting there by
the pool sunbathing it was German
yeah man that's how we met that was a
great [ __ ] week doesn't doesn't coke
make you want to like walk around and
like belie do stuff how do you how are
you getting a high on a bus for 12 hours
when you're stuck in a scene man I would
sit there by myself just get lost in
your thoughts right I bring a notebook I
think an OPM would bring water I would
sneak a beer oh yeah ma'am I would have
like a carry-on bag there was no dogs
then when you got into Mexico when you
stir the first time I went down the bus
the bus got pulled over on the way no
[ __ ] fourth of July weekend muscat
bulldog scary dogs came on and smote all
the code hospitai why slaughter he kept
barking weird but they can't be shared
if you are to snore it's too late but
that was it the guys never came on yeah
but that bus was today the thing about
that bus it was torture but it's what we
do would rather do this to this [ __ ]
we've had to but I remember one time I
was doing a triple run I hit black ice
my tire exploded and I had I had to make
the show
too bad I [ __ ] put on the donut and
did a tease the other the other 150
miles on I can't believe the donut made
it this [ __ ] other sauce let me clear
slow I've driven a dollar for two years
that's the [ __ ] you know right there
25 miles of it Oh Donal you get out of a
double I've gotten and I can top dog you
I had a donut on my nissan for
three-four punch taking for our triple
runs would not cheat the guide to a low
sir I think I drew those at one time you
think I'm [ __ ] keys on the front door
in the back when I was on the road those
cars were [ __ ] them once I figure
that was just all [ __ ] yeah it's
only a 25 mod thanks Jess you can go buy
tyre the next morning go to [ __ ] when
that thing goes then we'll get another
one that's what I used to do I used to
drive with the real tire in the back but
the donut I guess I know the donut would
go if you're the left-hand Lane that
right side of pops in it you [ __ ]
done though don't I used to have a car
when I first got here I had a crowd I
had no brakes no registration no I'm
sure that and whenever I would step on
the brake you would hear the metal like
I can see why you didn't drive at El
Paso that one no no that was local that
wasn't was from local gigs only I I
drove from Texas to Washington for the
turtle run drove from Texas had it I
remember one time I drove to host I've
lost money obviously but I just wanted
to try to get in with every club I could
that Club bananas and pick it see
remember that in the hotel drove from
Dallas Texas to go [ __ ] MC there okay
so whatever weekend let's do something
real quick
that's quite a lot just lies yeah
managed story all right so I met you
know pass yes and then that I work with
you and hattis them all yeah it was
after right after long as yard he worked
at uh yeah and you were you is you
requesting hey you want to come in
because that you know I was living there
and so I went hosted for you and ass in
a couple of times yeah yeah and then you
move to New York at one point yep about
2006 2000 four five six round how old
you stay in the euro about a year about
a year and then it just it got to the
you got mugged in New York I got my I
didn't want to leave I loved it I got I
didn't give a [ __ ] I got mugged I did a
show I did a spot the very next night my
[ __ ] face was purple it was after
here just blood everywhere I was like
[ __ ] it I wanted to this the night it
happened
the night it happened my may he rest in
peace my brother might be Stephano
he called me cuz I even hear from him we
used to hit me up when we get home from
the gig and he calls me and luckily I
had two cell phones out in New York cell
phone and my regular cell phone and my
New York cell phone I had with me it got
destroyed and he called me goes what the
[ __ ] were you been Oh Almighty I got
jumped because what not where the for
what [ __ ] street corner I'm like no
it's okay man cuz no no Jerry goes
you're doing me a favor my brother just
really wants to beat the [ __ ] out of a
couple of Porto Ricans then it's over
here tell me we're gonna happen we'll
bring some bats we'll let you get a
couple of shots I'm like nah but yeah I
went to the spot the very next night and
so I was in New York for about a year
and it just I Love New York
I loved it I [ __ ] loved it man and I
was getting love at some of the clubs I
was kind of you know but there was just
this weird because before I left I was
already passed at The Improv out here
right and so part of me just thought I
felt like man you remember you got me
that spot at the store and I was
starting to get a couple of those like
friends and family spots and I was like
man I just kind of missed LA you know
and I'm like I think I should be in LA
just for me personally and so I know you
lie first before legal I was in LA I was
staying with my buddy for a couple of
months on his sofa I remember that and
then and then then I went back to Texas
and then I went to New York and then
after New York and went back to Texas
saved up a shitload of money and then
came back here for good and that was a
whole have you been here for it that's
almost like 10 years now a little strips
yes straight yeah yeah and it was just
and I remember you told me yeah when I
remember when I moved here that when I
moved out of here the first time you
called me and you said you're gonna be
okay I remember you tell me was it was
it saved my life in a way cuz I was
thinking alike because you know how hard
it is when you have to move you know
what I mean and you told me goes look
you're gonna be okay you're gonna just
[ __ ] grind
come back and you're like trust me
coming back the second time is the
hardest move you ever gonna make but
you're gonna have to do it and I was
like yeah if luck you're right and you
just you know you grind through it and
you [ __ ] just sided man I worked
every [ __ ] a workday job shitty gigs
and practice in that period just to save
up enough money one year yeah I loved it
all [ __ ] I loved it man
I loved it man I Love New York I lived
in Astoria Queens it was right there
right off the end train man it was yeah
I loved it it was uh when I was there
for about a year it was great but I mean
we would talk a lot I remember that too
we talk all the time when I lived out
there cuz I didn't know anybody but Mike
you know Mike was my uh Mikey D and I
became instant friends but you know that
was it he was really one of the few
people I really knew in New York because
when I met him I was opening for
Stanhope at Caroline's and he was pissed
because he wanted to open for Doug but
Doug knew I just moved to New York goes
hey coming open for Mike [ __ ] and I went
over there and Mike was mad that he and
that's why I'm at big J big J was
hosting and it was odd big 2006 maybe
something like that yeah big J and it
was like and he was all this and he was
like he he was super cool to me
he was well those guys who's like hey
welcome to New York man he got me in
touch with a couple of Booker's and it
was great and I don't even I don't even
know if they remember that right but I
used to work for big J right now the big
J got me in touch with the Louis Louis
used to book a couple of rooms Gomez a
book a couple of rooms and he would he
would man just on big J's rec he got me
sight unseen it was really kind of a mat
it was really help it does a little bit
yeah and then and then [ __ ] yeah and
then and then Mike got me in at a club
that he knew the owners at and it was
you know and we would work that was the
ha and we were there in Times Square and
Times Square and we were there it was
look I know a lot of comics talk [ __ ]
about the room a but man Mike and I we
every night
[ __ ] almost six seven shows a night
it would start at 6:30 in the morning
it's 6:30 evening it end at 2:30 in the
morning
and every hour on the hour they had to
show rooms you just run upstairs and
downstairs and you stand you you can't
help but become a good comic right it
just you it's like [ __ ] you're in front
of two
wrists you're like goddamn you've really
got to bring it because the guy before
you just crushed it like [ __ ] okay you
know and it makes it made you really get
made you good and it was why did they
talk [ __ ] about the club hey just the
owner was you know I he was fine with us
but he just wasn't that kind of it yeah
yeah [ __ ] I mean I think he the problem
is I think he only pay the guys he liked
you mean so I was lucky enough to be a
guy that he likes but he would pay yeah
I mean you would lead to give you a wad
of cash every night you know stuff like
that you know it was man it was great
and but I just as much as I Love New
York I just had this nagging I wanted to
be back here I just saw him about LA I
just felt like I wanted to be back in LA
and not me and you know nothing against
New York but I just I just felt like it
just felt like there was something
missing like his I it felt like when I
was out here for those first few months
things were kind of starting to go good
and then what year was this 2004 and
then so and then my buddy that I was
staying with he had to leave in 2004
there was a lot of action going on I pat
buckles put me on that Latino laughs
vessel yeah you show yes like it was all
this [ __ ] was it was like [ __ ] this is
great like I was like man and then you
know it's just again the war I was
staying with my friend and he ran out of
money and he had to move back to Texas
and I was like [ __ ] so I was working at
a job at a t-mobile in Westwood and I
was like oh [ __ ] like I wasn't making
enough to afford you know taking over
the rent for that apartment and I was
like you know I was you know I was like
[ __ ] I don't have enough to just start
getting my own apartment now like fog
sounds like well I moved back to Texas -
and then that's when I say that Brad
moved to New York thought well let me
give me Orca try and I loved it but I
was like man and you were great
I mean you would always give me pep
talks like it's gonna be all right
whatever you have but you I say but you
you know whenever you want to come back
to LA we'll be here you know that well
it'll be waiting for you okay let me
tell you something I went to Cleveland I
took a red-eye yeah to Cleveland on
Wednesday night nice which I never take
right oh yeah all right I gotta tell you
is both this story because if something
happens this is the next show on patient
deal the next you know I'm pitching
is about those nine months I did in New
York where I really think about those
nine months those nine months really
made me a comic but it brought me back
to speed as character there's certain
times in your life when you have to do
something for maybe eight nine twelve
fourteen months and it seems like a bump
in the road but ten years later you look
at that and it's the best thing that
ever happened no question I was in a
horrible horrible state as a human being
as an individual what you guys call
depression I was stuck in living it and
I was started I was never starting to
lose reality or something
I was just down yeah the boulder place
had fired me as an emcee there was a new
comedy club opening Judy Brown had
talked these engineers from the
University of Colorado to uh to open up
a comedy club not to serve booze to
serve popcorns and hotdogs and everybody
said everybody sat on a desk you have no
idea the school bus and they called my
university kind of like honorable and it
was all p.g rain oh the [ __ ] Chinese
guy told me not to come around no more
than I was
oh I was beating this little Chinese do
for about a year out of money it would
all these open mics and she would bring
Cosby and Richard Pryor he wasn't there
I would bring a black guy and I would
saw the bottle I told him my brother
like all my avenues and dried up [ __ ]
I was just down and out always losing a
divorce I lost my job in the sports
betting service and I knew it I knew it
was time to touch new jersey ground I
had been through prison I got married I
got divorce I'd been I hadn't been all
been eight years and I had law
the pepper my step yeah and I knew it my
soul just needed to go back to that area
and start the scratch you know and I
went back in the first month I had a
cushy a buddy of mine I would just wake
up and everything he just peel off a
yardstick yeah give me a hundred a day
that's great like that nobody does that
yeah yeah he would give me his car if I
hadn't run errands are gonna new you're
the biblical grandma blah or whatever at
night I would stay with his wife we get
choice she was pregnant it was done
after that I moved to Fort Lee New
Jersey close I park and I live with
George mm-hmm George was a [ __ ] heroin
addict ouch me and George shared a room
the size of this office there was a
single little kids bed yeah like a
little kids bed that you feed him off of
and there was a couch George was a
gentleman so he took the couch and I
took the bet nice I had the bed while he
was in rear right okay I moved in with
his grandmother helped her while he was
in rehab so when he got a rehab he moved
on the couch and those were the most
fascinating eight months of my life he
taught me how to get up in the morning
again and go into the city and how to
make money selling cars and just it was
a brilliant time and something else
happened I figured out the equation of
comedy I figured out that you just
didn't get on stage I figured out that
if you want to write a joke you got to
write it and then add to it and it all
came to me and I was ready to pursue it
but I couldn't pursue it in New York
right I was just gonna spin my wheels
and leave today that's weird I felt the
exact that's it [ __ ] wife anywhere we
have New York I wasn't going to get to
that next level there was a big gap
that's I felt it raising yeah yeah yeah
there was just too big of a gap I didn't
have the the the the the the chops to
cover it right I did not have the chops
to cover it and there was no way I was
gonna get the chops living in New York
at that time yes if I knew one thing
about Denver was at the comics since The
Comedy Works was such a high level club
and they hand-picked that the comics
how to go out and hustle Denver taught
me how to do calmly the right way thank
God
and knock on wood yeah then I have to
bring four people he people ah man but
anyway to get back to this New Year
extent so it's September of 93 it's all
yes at 93 I'm doing okay yeah I'm doing
okay I'm getting onstage
maybe three times a week four times [ __ ]
yeah man yeah I'm not getting anywhere
I'm not getting any laughs I'm not
getting two ass I had two or three jokes
and but my my help was improving my all
because of this heroin addict it was
just I love torturing people and he was
perfect for me I just torched him at
night but he flipped the cards on me and
tortured me right but this is one Sunday
that I get up and I got about 18 dollars
in my pocket the joint I don't know how
I don't know what I did for breakfast
but it was one of the afternoon it's a
Sunday in New York it's warm out Jesus
Christ I'm 30-something years old it's
1993 I'm 30 years old I should be out
New York apathy meanwhile all I want to
do is go to Harlem and get a bag of weed
which I can't yeah I got 18 bucks oh I
got $10 to get two joints and like you
got lunch then I can eat a hot dog slice
a piece of metal but Jesus Christ is my
little rid of this pathetic I got $18
and we lived underneath a chick that had
a kid okay that's all I know
a chubby type Church advocate and one
day I'm sitting on the bed reading a
book of Mark Omni that's when there was
that magazine was out of all the comedy
club right yeah yeah oh yeah of course
yeah I'm reading this magazine I'm
reading the Judy Carla book that's when
I got Jean Perez comedy and I would you
you know I had this day job but I also
had this dream at this point yeah I'd
seen Jay Leno in New Year
I'd seen a couple people and now I knew
I wanted to go to it I just seem like
reasonable now I was just waiting to get
out of I was trying to figure out how to
get out of [ __ ] New York puts New
York just I was just an addict in New
York right New York it's too easy to get
drugs and Jesus isn't it crazy it was
just too easy I mean I don't need to uh
you know me I'm clean now do any of that
[ __ ] was junkies [ __ ] you could get my
animals would give me money to get them
coke and so the days I didn't want to
get high and I was enough getting high
it was just that's what the wrong with
these customers for me everything was
too available
yeah so there's one son them sit there
in my 18 dollars it's 2:30 in the
afternoon and and there was a barbecue
grill in the backyard and I see the mom
coming out with the barbecue grill a
little boy yeah and she opens up the
barbecue grill and she's putting burgers
on the stuff now I have lived in this
building in 85 and I've lived in this
building now in 93 and I had robbed this
building the first time on the third
floor there was a couple I was just
robbing them once a week like you know
like if they had left an unlit I think
they left five 20s I would take three
twice and I would take that credit card
using then put it back a week later they
had a psychic well that's where it is I
don't know where nothing was yeah they
had a stack of credit cards in the desk
I was robbing them every like two or
three days they don't always put money
in this circle I would I would steal
something every three or four days
so it's 93 they would well I left I
remember George saying to me when he
came to Colorado so yeah man the girl
upstairs called the cops they said but
did you know I need to do one that
enjoys never accused me then Holland
right so now it's 93 they leave it out
you deserve it if you leave your [ __ ]
out like that how [ __ ] stupid are you
man come on so it's site name George his
grandma would leave on Sunday so George
can had the green light to shoot heroin
right so by Sunday he was broke and he
would save just a little taste
just and look together why right yeah so
I see
grandma leaves for that way hey let's
get something goes until the battle
blasts off and I can see he's coming
back oh man he would watch that stupid
[ __ ] show on TV Beavis and Butthead
I up me up so he's watching Beavis and
Butthead giggling all knotted up on
heroin and [ __ ] like and I see this lady
cooking and I run upstairs to her
apartment
no plugs the front door I knock first I
open up the front door and look in this
a table with a purse in the middle of
the flowers I believed in the table and
this an envelope sticking out of it like
a deposit and I look at it I just take
the envelope close the door and like go
downstairs I know the bathroom I can't
not like eight bills right I take the
envelope I rip it up into a thousand
pieces and I flush it down the toilet I
like take the 800 I take it and I had in
the mailbox somebody would but if
somebody was upstairs now by 6:00 Sunday
then I gotta check and write and I just
waited I ain't that stupid
I know this is not so we're laying on
the bed he's all [ __ ] up on the heroin
died right there in the kid you upstairs
with the cooked meal and it's not 20
minutes and I hear I already had
problems of George is there being the
building there was a heroin addict so
she's like [ __ ] the grandma hope was it
though hello she's like is your grandson
home I'm missing a house
I know was [ __ ] is the only heroin
[Laughter]
grandma's going now he's been laying
down the whole time
[ __ ] and he goes charge wake up this
lady say that you have been [ __ ] up
and I'm sitting there giggling inside I
can not laugh at all I could not like
I'm just holding it in and now the cops
come oh there's two cops in the hallway
thing I judge out there and he's [ __ ]
God
and [ __ ] the cops asked him to be
Robert yeah huh he's like I'm telling
you was him I left on top of the day
oh he's and I'm sitting back there how's
my ass pretending to read the newspaper
like you know like I'm napping right
then I'll son I get up when I get
involved I go what's going on George it
was this [ __ ] man he's accusing me
around my god George hasn't moved at all
no be writing lady and she's [ __ ]
crying oh I'm feeling bad enough as it
is
right it's a dog-eat-dog you know at
that time I was crazy and I felt roots
totally I feel really bad right but I
couldn't give it back at that point you
enjoyed that George outside flight 30
paws up they're all [ __ ] up on heroin
they made him into his pockets you
should so boom
I [ __ ] wait like an hour I let
everything calm down
I told George I'm gonna walk into the
city I get the 800 out and I'm gonna
Chinese restaurant but then 15 all right
all right at the enchanted Lilly the
shredded beef oh my god Szechuan
shredded beef oh and I was over the city
I went picked up like an eight ball I
went down and picked up this girl I know
I went crazy for a night and I gave my
money lay two days later but I never
told that's crazy
I leave October Cherie we reconnect in
99 2000 only 2005 one night were a
restaurant I doubt he's high on the hair
right no he's straight now he's been
sober for a long rate
yeah he's been sober since 96
oh that's good for him no I tell him the
story he goes I remembered that you
[ __ ] I was high as [ __ ] you put
he'll decide Thursday when he's up he's
at a bar in Cliffside Park and he said
there you girls at the bar next to him
and guys I don't know what they're
watching
Ransdell at football where the Giants
Allah Allah
it was just Thursday well who played
this Thursday
he said that the girls next to him asked
him if he was from the neighborhood he
goes yeah the girl goes I'm from
Cliffside Park originally and he goes
really goes where'd you live in she goes
in with Terrace let's get the [ __ ] out I
can live I grew up on him with Terrace
she goes wage Olivia 750 for him with
Terrace and he says to himself
come on I lived in with terraces where'd
you live I lived in that same building
oh yeah girl goes we lived in the second
floor
haha so one day my mom got robbed you
know there is when I take a red iron
that night the boy was picking me up
after yeah my call time was between 8:30
and 8:45
he called 810 I'm thinking to myself
it's George I'll just call him because I
had the baby in the living room yeah
we'll watch some TV shows my last 20
minutes well I don't want to be on the
phone sure so I figured I'll call George
back on the drive tube when I call him
back he's found by himself he goes let
me tell you he told me the story that
he's talking to the girl ah knows he
just stopped once he said because he got
robbed
he stopped because he knew if he's older
and his grandmother was the super the
demon no that is [ __ ] great man I
can't look has that ever happened me
before like when you were living in
Jersey would someone sit next to you and
be like the person you robbed right
that's that is a crazy that's a [ __ ]
crazy coincidence man to have one of the
odds what a [ __ ] AHA it's amazing my
mom we got robbed we left we booze two
months later or something
Brian [ __ ] that's great
[ __ ] so well how many know you have a
Netflix special yeah it was only on for
a year but yeah I was up there for you
yeah that hadn't been for a year now and
now I'm doing my CD on Thursday how long
will we be dual family totally oh god
since I was 17 yeah I start walking so
I'm 41 now [ __ ] that's been the minute
24 24 years 24 years I've been doing
comedy three or four years long mm-hmm
yeah about yeah baby wall I started yeah
started in 95 right right in the right
before I graduated actually after I
graduated high school so it was after
the summer it like the beginning of
summer like no they had like an August
at the end of seven August I started
doing open mics and Dallas up any money
but I live in how old do you know God
since New York so about 12 years I guess
knock on wood yeah yes okay how long to
start making a living at least ten at
least five just consistent yeah yeah
yeah but because it was always like cuz
I don't have a day job that's great when
you have a day job and you get like
three weeks a yeah I'm fine all the
[ __ ] video games I'm going to game
stuff and I'm like yes about being a
local comic I was a local job that yeah
okay [ __ ] yeah how was your bills and
then you do there's three different
timely clubs on our part
and each of them give you a week you
know every month of five hundred three
hundred six like they do you make it a
kill then yeah you have no idea how
great it was when I'd be like you know I
pay all my bills from work and then I'd
be like I just have like a couple of
bucks leftover that sucks and then kind
of scary you know and then boom we're
Andy from hyenas calls me hey I'm gonna
come down to Arlington this weekend [ __ ]
yeah I'll be that you know that all the
best the [ __ ] I remember those days I
would go to work at the bookstore I have
a clock out run to the bathroom put on
nicer clothes and then drive down to
Arlen
than do spot and hyenas you know oh yeah
that was the best man that was great
that was just so you ever get
discouraged along Hawaii every I get
discouraged every night but yeah I got
the others discouraged this morning yeah
I get it because I don't I don't think
this ad look I'm not trying to belittle
what people do but I think if you're if
you're not just working if you are
chasing something that's been in your
heart since as long as you can for me it
was four years old when my aunt my aunt
Sandra took me to go see Beverly Hills
Cop when it came out I was in [ __ ] I
think second I forgot how all that was
maybe second grade I was maybe because
when I was four I snuck out and saw
delirious at my grandmother's house
because she had HBO we didn't have HBO
but when I go visit my grandmother in
Laredo she had HBO and I snuck out in
the night and I saw Eddie Murphy
delirious and I was four or five I had
no idea what the [ __ ] he was said and
know what half of it meant but when he
did the thing about the Andy's got the
mustache and all that and ice cream
I was all God I was I was like this is a
greatest thing I've ever seen and then
and then I loved Dana Carvey on Senate
Live Weird Al Yankovic Eddie Murphy and
Monty Python those four things were just
I would you know and then so when I was
a kid my aunt took me to see Beverly
Hills Cop when it came out in a theater
I think it was like in first grade I
would say [ __ ] recess the very
next day I got with to the principal's
office but like I make kids cry because
I say [ __ ] I was like no I think
it's funny but when something is in your
heart for that lon
meet comedy is what I wanted to do since
I was for it you're gonna get
discouraged even if things are going
great you're gonna get discouraged
because for whatever reason there's
always that nagging voice in your head
that's telling you you still aren't
doing what you really wanted to be you
know what I mean like whatever that is
it's like there's this mythical extra
rung on a ladder that your [ __ ] soul
or whatever your insecurity creates and
it makes you feel like you just you're
nothing if you aren't grabbing it and I
always feel like I'm not grabbing it
like I always feel like I'm still
reaching for something that I've you
know I don't know but yeah I always [ __ ]
yeah dude I get discouraged all the time
an hour after I have
that's why I think people do heroin and
people do things like that especially
entertainers because an hour after you
crush you're back to just being Jerry
you're back to just being Joey you're no
longer that guy who just had 500 people
crying and screaming and cheering now I
just go back and I'm just as [ __ ]
dude alone in a [ __ ] hotel room right
and that's all I am and that's that's
what I that's the hard part is I just
sit there and like [ __ ] I'm just this
dude who's just [ __ ] it all by
himself in a town you've never been in
before and I'm just here you know and
then sometimes when you're on the road I
remember I was I was working with this
guy I forgot his name but he had Crohn's
disease the headliner so you're sitting
there just depressed that you're working
some shitty gig in South Bend Indiana
right and you're in this shitty condo
and if that isn't bad enough you're just
alone with your thoughts you hear this
guy taking a [ __ ] like every other hour
just [ __ ] horrific [ __ ] and you're
just sitting there right next to it you
know your bedroom right next to the
bathroom so you just get woken up and
the whole night but this guy just
[ __ ] you like mother you know like
[ __ ] but you had a great set that night
so that's what you remember that at
least a little bit like yeah but I did
that and not many people can say that
they went and smashed a room so [ __ ]
yeah okay I'll keep fighting and that's
but yeah do not get discouraged all the
time all the time it just cuz it's you
know it's a do it fit your comedies been
in your heart
I've got longer than you even know right
like you probably don't even realize I
bet if you start if somebody were to
hypnotize you they would probably find
any memories I like the art okay I liked
I liked the art of laughing yeah and I
liked the art of making people laugh
Larry oh I never dreamed of stand-up
really I own an Hou thinking back like
yeah I was funny on the bus yeah well it
was 10 of us and I could torch Ali and
then he was short on me and Lee would
torture me back we all grew up together
we're on the basketball team together
that scenario I was good I didn't know
about the solo [ __ ] on stage you know
what we got that for me was my first
ever
formants was in when I was a kid my my
uncle my aunt's husband him and his
brothers in Laredo would have these kind
of nice Ava's and they would just have
me they would they would give me
quarters like like you know dollars in
quarters change but if I would just go
do impersonations I was like five years
six years old and they would love it
they would start giving me money and I
was like well that feels good and then
when I was in fifth grade
I was a class clown right I was always
trying to make my friends laugh in class
and the teacher pulled me aside I'll
never forget this my fifth grade teacher
Aven Cravens may he rest in peace he
pulled mr. Cravens he pulled me aside
and he goes hey you wanna can I cut you
a deal right now and I said sure what am
I in trouble and he goes no no it goes
just do me a favor if you don't
interrupt my lesson to tell a joke every
Friday I'll let you tell five minutes of
jokes at the end of class and I'm like
[ __ ] yeah deal shook on it and at every
Friday at the end of class I would go up
and do five minutes I was just in person
to good principal you know stupid [ __ ]
like that but the kids loved it and I
was like oh my god that felt good and
that was it I just knew that we planted
it and I was in high school on a date
with my girlfriend at the time junior
year and we would always go to this
comedy club called the back door and
that was still there in Dallas and it
was like because it was like it was
cheap wasn't as expensive as The Improv
right like it was easier for like high
school kids to afford to go you know and
they were a cleaner room so they allowed
younger people to go in there like he
didn't have to buy booze that kind of
[ __ ] you know and so we would just go
and watch comedy and they just had a
sign I was getting ready to graduate the
next year senior year it's getting ready
to graduate we've been going all junior
year and then senior year and I just saw
him with a sign say hey do you think
you're funny try or open-mike and I'm
like [ __ ] that's what I want to do it's
just that it was just that because I was
about to go to Community College I have
no idea what the [ __ ] you know what I
mean and then I was like that's it I
that is it that's oh yeah that's what I
want to do duh like alright and then so
I just wrote three minutes of the
unfunniest [ __ ] you could [ __ ] imagine
and I just went up and that was it I
just never stopped going up no matter
what was happening I'd always go up on
there Wednesday hoping Mike's always and
I remember man
felt like a champion when they gave me
that first ever Friday night spot oh
dear and I was like 18 I've been doing
it for like five months like yeah you're
doing good we think you're ready you
want you come into a Friday oh man I
thought that was good I'm like wow yeah
it was that was fun man that was when
you were 23 did you have any doubts
about staying the panel oh yeah oh yeah
I never want we what were you saying 23
I thought I don't know I I just 23 was
about the time
do you remember CW Kendall you ever work
for him yes 23 was about the time that I
was in with him and that and I was
touring with Niall Edwards and he would
he would get me hooked in with clubs and
I would start to call him on my own and
he always told me that goes look I can
get you in the door but they're not
gonna remember you you know no matter
how good you do they're not gonna
remember the kid who went up and did ten
minutes like you're gonna have to stay
on him and so I would [ __ ] call Bynum
every day at laughs I would call Randy
at hyena's I would call the imp every
day 23 I call CW Kendall it was just to
Sanh at that point cuz got that guy yeah
I was a Tucson and I think at that point
Albuquerque was already Russ Reedus I
believe I think right around there is
when we're uh services already had
Albuquerque and so but so and then Jeff
Jones the loony Bin's up in he had
Memphis at the time uh Little Rock and
Tulsa and then now he's gotta give every
to the Oklahoma City Wichita Kansas
right and so I would call him and he was
stood that dude Jeff Jones say that that
those loony Bin's
those clubs I think so yeah they saved
my ass so many times I remember I would
just be like they were I would get a
phone call because that that is it's
like you said like I don't know I don't
know man like his you know me like I'm
not as I'm not that religious of a
person my grandmother would [ __ ] kill
me if she heard me saying this but like
I'm not that religious of a person but I
do believe inside I don't think you have
to I think if you like you said if we
talked before the show if you're a
grinder like you have to believe you
know and I remember there was those
times when I would get discouraged you
know what maybe I'm not gonna make it as
a comedian
maybe I should just try to climb my way
up this [ __ ] bookstores corporate
ladder me enough just and then and then
Jeff Jones calls me out of the blue hey
what are you doing next weekend
[ __ ] this is the paid gig [ __ ] yeah and
that keeps you and then when I moved out
here you have those moments of doubt
where I have ten dollars in my bank
right and I'm not getting paid until
next Friday and I'm like [ __ ] what am I
gonna do in the back when Emily used to
help book The Improv she called me hey
you want to come middle for us starting
tomorrow [ __ ] does that lightning hits
of like [ __ ] yeah thank god this is
gonna keep me afloat for another month
this is you know what I mean those
moments dude they happen a lot and it's
god bless somebody yelling but I but I
so around 23 I was just I was still
working at the book store of course but
every morning every Monday morning I
would get up and call in avails to all
the clubs that I met the one-nighter
Booker's that I've met I just stayed on
him [ __ ] calling everybody I'd ever
known that at that point I would just I
had a little address book and every time
I met got in with a new Club Med a
Newport GK's in Beaumont I would call
them all the time black company yes the
the black couple that owned it inside
the Hilton remember inside the Hilton
GK's I would call them and that's when
that guy dick Williams was booking it
and I so he I would call dick every day
[ __ ] just say hey man you know sorry
to bug you but here's here my avails
what's a face cap city's the Velveeta
room Texas at the time had a lot of
rooms so he bothers rocky bottoms in in
Abaddon they've had three clubs in
Houston three in Houston there was a
fella
well they had they had Don learner's
room they had Danny Martinez his room
you had a peach room and the guy but
forgot who was who was a guy before Pete
who had to stop [ __ ] I forgot his name
but you know I'm talking about you the
one that everybody thought owned it I
thought he owned it I didn't know he was
mentally yeah yeah and then and
Spellbinders right so you had those four
rooms when I was starting in Houston and
then there was a room in Lubbock the
froggies was in Lovick I think there was
a room in Abilene like they had all
these [ __ ] little and then and you
know everything's always won there was
always one room that was a front for
drugs that would be in Midland the other
place Odessa and then we little Odessa
AB yeah mm-hmm but Corpus Corvis had a
room the drug room corpus had a drug
room Oh Stu you're from
yeah Laredo and it's an intense
Antonio had to add a room and then
Lorado have you been to hell yeah it's a
great room it's gorgeous
it's a [ __ ] boy I still like the
river center though because that's where
that was my first one is that River
Center no no I still like to represent
but it's the same guy they own a bow so
it's lol and then the River Center is
now The Improv they call the day they
it's now an improv but it's the same
owners it's still the dude it's still
that guy who owns them both yeah but the
one inside the mall is the Improv the
one inside the malls the Improv we used
to be the River Center and then the
lol's like in its own it's more like
because the River Center still the end
of improv is still downtown you know and
the lol is more like heart of San
Antonio like middle of the city
Tabitha okay so yeah so what you want to
work lol yeah it's a that's a badass
room but yeah like it was uh so that I
mean it you would and in Laredo because
I was from there you know every now and
again you get a phone call from hey you
know I talked to your cousin he said
you're a comedian hey I want to do a
comedy night if I give you like 300
bucks yeah like you would just get those
things you know and so I would spend I
remember I would give this before I had
a cell phone so I would just I would
give a lot of Booker's the phone number
for the bookstore I'd say just whoever
answers just ask for just to be
transferred to the music department you
know if they would get that's how I
would get some gigs they were called
okay hey that's me yeah I'll be there
you know it [ __ ] like that for sure man
that was the night yeah there was also a
payphone two outside in inside by the
bathroom right outside the music
department and it was kind of risky but
sometimes I forget that number out and I
was just kind of keeping air but I would
hear it ring and I would just run over
it real quick and answer and there every
now and again it would be a gig yeah
I'll be there
you know like [ __ ] crazy just do we
had to do man like it but yeah it's just
I don't know if I'm and it's kind of
depressing but I don't know if I'm ever
not gonna still get discouraged right
but I know this is where I'm gonna sound
like a [ __ ] lunatic
I think it's in a way I like it because
it makes me hungry still it makes me
think you know what yeah I did really
well I've what I put out let's put out
one special in two CDs three hours of
content whatever I'm still hungry
I still don't think I'm good enough yet
and I always want to feel that way I
don't know if I always want to be that
discouraged but I always want to feel
like I'm just not quite good enough I
always want to feel like nice
to work I still go to work I still gonna
work cuz I don't ever want to be my dad
made rest in peace he he told me this he
was when I first started doing comedy he
told me a story about how when he loves
stand-up when he was a kid and he
remember he watched a guy on The Tonight
Show this is way back away right in like
the 60s and here dad was like what's a
deal with the funky chicken Mikey was
making fun of all these dances of
teenagers to do and he goes man I
thought that guy was a funniest comic
ever and then he was on The Tonight Show
two years later and I was all excited
and he's like what's a deal what the
[ __ ] if he's just doing the same [ __ ]
and I was like ah I'm so bummed out it
wasn't funny anymore and I just always
remembered like you've been with those
dudes we've both worked with those I
mean no offense zoom god bless him for
being out there but there's there's been
some cheeseball headliners that you and
I have had to open for that you know
they're doing the same jokes the same
act that they did ten years ago right
it's never changed it worked form once
and I don't ever want to fall into that
trap of thinking that all it's is good
enough right and I think that is why I
get discouraged twos I never want to
think like I just want to always be
hungry
I always want to have like a little bit
of a chip on my shoulder not it not a
really devastating one returned is on
[ __ ] but you don't I mean just have
that kind of little chip to be like nah
[ __ ] that I still want to try to prove
that I'm good at this no never a comedy
fan really like I would never even think
of going on Khan becoming my world and
was finally in Boulder where I wanted to
see a comedian yeah and I went back the
following yeah because my friend knew
somebody or you won tickets and I never
forget that comedian never wrote a new
joke that wasn't even thinking of doing
Tom sure but I bet you feel ripped off
right I was saying to myself if I was
over convenient I would have new
material right I remember having that
and not even thinking of being a comic
right like at that point my life the
farthest thing from my mind was getting
onstage or gray right right doing movies
or anything I thought that it was out of
my realm so when I became a comic I
always have to fall back about telling
people by your deck worst case in our
you know I learned early on at the
two or three dmy yeah in all those rooms
that you do every night that the best
thing to do is just tell them by your
day no question without the two jokes
you wrote and talked about your day and
tape it and listen to it and if you do
that four nights a week you'll get three
new [ __ ] minutes a week always it's a
week it's nonstop that's what I did when
I moved to Boulder back to Boulder in 94
I was 93 and a half after I lived a
junkie yeah like I was really tuned in
sure okay this is what needs to be done
I got the notebook I got the pen I would
still write renegade style yeah but I
wrote that's all that matters I still
wrote renegade style but I wrote I took
a lot of chances I learned in New York
to take chances you have to so I took
chances of material every night I wanted
to something new just to feel it out to
see how I could chop it up and that took
years to develop the chopped up game
takes another [ __ ] five years that
happens while you perform yes and you
learn the chopped up game you know last
week I put a clip up I put a clip up
that Rick Ramos put up nice of Sam for
this you know I still remember the night
we used to get Pete's on Friday nights
me and a lot of merchants and we'd watch
Sanford and Son we throw in the man
still the best average son still a
[ __ ] bass man but I still remember
and if you watch the wording of it he
says to him there in the courtroom scene
and they've cut up and I don't want to
put it on because you to just really
yank it down I know what you're talking
about
we're red Foxx over at Fox oh my god but
we got enough to me yeah so funny if you
look at the wording of that now if you
look at the see who wrote that episode I
don't know if he wrote no lettuce you
know right but I know that he was one of
the writers on the show at that time
it's Paul moon ah yeah better I bet that
was handy watch how he delivers it he
goes first and he goes I ain't doing
young I like to ask the arresting
officer a couple of questions and the
judge says well who were you he was
counsel
yes at business council I love you but
it's Council for all his life all right
he may proceed
he walks up to the guy first and he says
what do you have against black people
and the judge says incorrect or whatever
the [ __ ] he says objection objection and
he goes he doesn't have anything against
black people I'm like I'm and he goes
yeah buta anything goes gonna ask the
arresting officer couple more questions
and then he walks I was like I was
already thinking what do you have
against black people because I don't
know anything we can supply papers those
don't you arrest me no do you arrest me
white people right he goes yes I do them
well how are they against Edwards and he
who's your friend we're gonna make a
Tarzan movie
God that was television 19 yeah 75 could
never do that today but watch how he
said it he said black first and then he
set it up with and that's that's poor
morning all genius writing all he could
go with something black yeah Edward back
to black back to [ __ ] you know yep 22
[ __ ] back to black me ya know he was a
genius of that why cut that out you know
that could never happen again today but
that's not the point at the point of it
was the writing the structure of it you
know performing is one thing now you
have to learn the act of structure s
which some people have naturally some
people know how the structures amazing I
never know how this drug right right
never had segues oh god I had to learn
that I have to learn that great segue
hey so I would just tell the joke and
then go to another one everybody comics
I would blow off the stage early on that
would call me mister no segue who's
getting laughs who's getting laid
don't matter [ __ ] it laughs yeah man
why are you there focused on the [ __ ]
it's so weird how my Netflix special
game on today anyways I see that they're
the only knock that I have against the
special I think Netflix did a great job
yeah Jeff Tomczyk was on the show
whatever is that I focus too much on the
words okay yeah sure sir
you know if I have to look back at it
now and see what the only not I have is
my own shortcomings I focus too much on
the verbage they didn't focus on my
heart which down sometimes how you
learned all these things that through
experience you know it's like when you
do a TV show and you have to learn the
words you can rehearse the words 20
times and all of a sudden you'll feel it
I'll go through you and now you correct
the line yeah the perfect way for both
of my specials see so in fact and the
seesaw I corrected it yeah of the seaso
of the first show I focus too much on
the script and I ate a bag of dicks you
have that I can show y'all off script
and I did write a lot better than rag or
show you know it's just so weird that
this nepalese special that's the only
knock I have I think I did great we
likes it yeah my agent I said you know I
just think that I focus too much on the
words and that's what fouled me up a
little bit but I'm like max Holloway and
the other guy I got a lot better yeah
there's so much of it
you're gonna they're gonna laugh at me
from making it about this but do you
ever hear the Empire Strikes Back story
the best line in any Star Wars movie
right is Han Solo Harrison Ford's about
to get frozen the capture him it's in
part two right and everybody thinks he's
gonna die and finally Princess Leia just
says I love you and in the script
Harrison Ford says I love you too he did
20 takes and he hated it it wasn't
working and he told her just please let
me do this and so she goes I love you
and he goes I know and that that's the
most memorable moment next to Darth
Vader saying I am your father right and
he because he went off-script followed
us you know he went now this is what
this is what this is what my heart's
telling me this guy should [ __ ] say
made him the coolest [ __ ] character
in movie
you know what I mean just the mode the
guys facing death
he doesn't say I love you to the I know
and then boom that was it but that is
how [ __ ] badass that was and that's I
I get so scared of that too because
before I tape any kind of CD or special
I recite it over and over and over again
but I try to like make sure that I have
all the beats down but I also leave room
in my head in case I want to take a
quick little detour it's okay that's you
have to tell yourself right look it's
okay
because it's your script you know what I
mean you're nobody else wrote this we
wrote it so if I want to go off it [ __ ]
it it's mine I can go off it right like
that's how you gotta look at it like
it's still tough though because you know
in your head you think oh this is
perfect way I got to do it like that you
know but yeah like it's [ __ ] man it's
your own organic thing you [ __ ] do
what you want with it right like but
it's tough because I know man I can take
it you get into that trap like ah [ __ ] I
have to do it this way and that's it and
then if you oh I think every comic
should leave a little bit of room you
know what I mean
just a little bit of room to go off and
just let's go here now let's go and
that's what I felt I didn't do yeah yeah
you're right you're absolutely right you
have to have that a little bit you look
on me from such an obscure waste of time
especially when you think the stakes
around the wine you think differently
and that's what I learned
I mean Netflix was great yeah shooting
if it was great sure Jeff Tomczyk was
great the stand reads in the hotel I
just I think the special is great thing
yeah I think you'll guys enjoy yeah I
just think that out that's what was
missing a little bit and I think of you
see me now you'll see that I picked that
that part up right Wow all right that's
not gonna happen again I'm not gonna
worry too much on this Shane I'm saying
it's just very weird Jerry that I've
grown up with a bunch of people I've
shared a quarter of my life with a bunch
of people in this game and you're one of
them I doubt when I met you were a kid
and you know for a couple weeks I don't
want to put you on you know just to let
you know that you're a [ __ ] grinder
yeah I means a lot and I mean grinders
I'm a grinder yeah I'm a grind and I
love it we would we remember it I don't
wanna name names I breathing
my name's but God they remember those
comics the you and I you would call me
sometimes I'll never forget those you
call me at like 1:00 in the morning go
to some to the website right and we both
be reading the bio and just howling
remember that we cheese balls
and we'd be like these [ __ ]
don't put any work in they just do the
same [ __ ] over and over and over and
over and over they think they have it
made I'll never forget I was in Bart's
room and I look I'll be cool I'm not
gonna say any of you know who was I'm
not gonna say who it was but I told you
to start the headliner that I was
working with was on the phone back when
Trey was in Addison and he was talking
to Trey and he goes man [ __ ] those la
people Dave they would they want to come
find me they know where I'm at and I
remember you could you were dying I told
you that story I called you from the
condo and that guy was asleep and I'm
like Joe you're not gonna move you not
gonna believe what I just heard and you
we were howling and you were like look
nobody's gonna go [ __ ] over there to
find this dumb [ __ ] oh my god we would
do that all the stinking comedy is in
the beginning you work with a lot of
junk you work with all that
and when I say junkets it's I shouldn't
even say that you work with you work
with people who have been beat up by
this business yeah yes with people that
I I can't say that it I'm not saying
they didn't put the work in but maybe
somewhere they cut it a piece out and
they came to Iowa and they had zero
success on that land and now they have
to live in that way so they have to take
these weird rooms to pay their rent and
I mean they would tell me like I'm
paying my least oh yeah I work with
these guys in October and then lease is
over in the same job and they were
miserable and all they would do is talk
about how awful LasR boil a wall you
just gotta be an ass kisser that's the
only way you're making a lot the Sun
dick yes you don't know how many times
ever yeah
it had to be yeah I've heard up of oh
yeah don't go out yeah don't go out
there there's a level of it people that
exist that you cannot believe like
you're an excited guy you want me to a
place you're so exciting you don't give
a [ __ ] you don't see it for what it is
yeah it's a [ __ ] dive bar
but do you Carnegie Hall it's Carnegie
yeah yeah yeah and you walk in as a
feature act you get your hotel there's
two hindus behind the desk you know the
family lives there you could smell the
Hindu food I still might as well be at
the restoral right you called
there's a Chandler has dirty move yes
but the guy has to switch the VA
sometimes he's jerking off and he goes
let's switch it I mean the hotels that
this was way before free breakfast
mm-hmm this is way before they gave you
a hard-boiled egg and white bread right
oh yeah you got nothing for breakfast
you know do you remember your saying
those hotels I know you have I know yeah
we probably talked about this before
we're like yeah the gig the club puts
you in a hotel and the room next to your
room is a pimps room and he's just
having chicks go turn tricks in that
room all [ __ ] night and you could
just hear it you just like oh [ __ ]
that's I mean it is crazy the [ __ ]
place is really saying I can't like that
was Tucson Tucson condo no the hotel oh
yeah how's that Rudy used to put you up
when you played the club Bugsy's right
and if you showed up with a bug village
in force [ __ ] you know people understand
these things to you I like especially
when you get a flyer with your name on
it's heaven man and you performing on a
Wednesday night is some [ __ ] place
and you get there that's him like I
stole him a Marc Babbitt God right now
he's still alive yeah that was it
Babbitt yes
book me Freddie and maybe Bobby Lee in a
barn it was a barn it was like Melvin's
calmly
my lord and they threw the cattle out
that like that day yeah they swept up
the hay
it's at 500 people and her be from the
town was there oh man I think he paid me
$400 Danny bad and no plane ticket right
in those days I would take the I would
buy a plane ticket to Houston that
connected in San Antonio and I jump off
the plane in this Arizona take the bus
to Corpus because it was a lot cheaper
yeah I mean you had to pull tremendous
scales but yeah that was the scam and
then I would go to the airport in San
Antonio this is before 9/11 and they
would go what are you talking about you
got to get on the plane and Houston and
you're like I missed it so I drove it
and I will let you on this time but
don't let that bad you don't know how
it's all about the tank because the
direct flight to San Antonio was a lot
of my way more expensive but if you went
to Houston it was $2 cheap yeah and I
connected in San Antonio this is way
before 9/11 you can't do this now I'll
throw you in [ __ ] jail when I first
moved out here I I didn't tell any train
ooh who used to run Addison and Randy
Butler new right because they kind of
you know they were nice cuz yeah but but
the clubs in Houston Austin San Antonio
I didn't tell him I moved I was just
there are times where they called me hey
can you come feature tomorrow and I did
it I packed my [ __ ] and I drove from LA
to Houston in one sitting
made it in time to take a small nap try
to recharge and then go do this [ __ ] you
know I did that a bunch man LA the hue
see I did that I did that twice I'm
totally for hours I did it twice one
thing I did it one time it was boy you
feel it right remember like but you do
bite but I did two times the first time
but a bunch of times I would just like I
did they would give me a little bit of
advance notice so I would like get a
hotel I would go halfway but a bunch of
times I would do that go halfway and
aadya I didn't tell him I'd live cuz I
that was a lot of work they would give
me when I lived in Texas that trip you
start up in LA yeah and the fur
stop is Tempe yep you take your legs out
you fill up to take a pass take a piss
get a [ __ ] sandwich and then your
next bottle is El Paso now pass over
here for view is step enough maybe you
get the van horn right yeah but you
gotta fill up you have Filipino paso if
you're gonna make it to Van Horn up
their [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] there's
nothing good
you better be filled up without pants oh
yeah you better be tip-top Magoo you're
better you battery's better beat yes if
you're tired just trended I know pass on
the Freak is that the rest of it is that
the rest of that's the real test that's
the real test
oh that's cactuses for four hours no gas
station no radio god forbid it's in the
summertime during all that was the radio
which shut off its 802 had a
hundred-plus outside humid and you're
[ __ ] like uh oh god it was man Jesus I
remember those saying yeah you had no
radio to listen to so that's I I would
make I would burn yeah that would burn
my ohmic CDs and save them for that trip
for that part of the trip I got put in
my own music and [ __ ] you just oh my god
well it's the longest that you drove
that was it that has even led all [ __ ]
yeah I'd say the worse though was one
time the guy who owned the ha in in New
York he had sweet Caroline's it was a
room in Virginia Beach and I he would go
headline there right every now and again
it was always great but one time after
it already left New York I was still in
Texas before I came out here and I was I
was he goes hey can you I had a guy fall
out I know you're in Texas I'll give you
a couple extra hundred bucks
you I'll give you a couple days notice
right and come out here I was like [ __ ]
ad drove headline that room and as I was
headline it was closing it out [ __ ] I
forgot what it was but he had me stay a
cook it was like a seven night a week
room right and he had me he had me stay
until like Tuesday I forgot why but I
think the guy backed down so I was there
until Tuesday did the weekend I was
there till Tuesday the next week and
then he calls me Jeff Jones calls me in
Little Rock goes hey you wanna come in
middle and I'm like [ __ ] I can make
Virginia Beach and I and I was trying to
nap
in the club I was trying to nap in the
[ __ ] in the club before I left and this
local comment kept bouncing jokes off of
me like and I was too nice to tell him
to go [ __ ] off and he kept waking me up
to tell me hey what do you think maybe I
should say this instead and I'm like
yeah that's great man like tried in half
and that so I was already a zombie and I
get in my car after the Late Show
Tuesday and I'm drew the show and I'm
driving to Little Rock and I'm a I don't
know how I made it the last I have no
memory of the last two hours of the trip
no memory I was like oh [ __ ]
I don't know how I got here but I made
it like it was crazy but the longest
that was about 20 maybe something like
that but the longest was Houston to LA
for certain one sitting [ __ ] man
it was crazy I've done LA to Dallas -
and once it had done hello to Detroit Oh
Baltimore Oh probably my long that's
gotta be what close to 30 Colorado the
Baltimore rain welcome whoa whoa yeah
what stopped in Michigan yeah through
the weekend in Michigan and drive back
to Colorado I was the longest and then
the longest in the car that I was had to
be eight months yeah in a car like I had
one shot yeah then the second time the
last time I did it was like six months
or something yeah something not natural
right yeah you know what it's time to
get out of the [ __ ] car
because it's fun at first it is oh it's
great it's a great journey it's a great
way to learn it's a great place to see
the country you see a lot of writing a
lot of material you write so much
material just being around these and
then but by going to summer camp for
Stan yeah that's exactly what it is you
committed six months of your life to
summer camp to stand up but once you
take a plane no planes really there's no
planes you know it there's no plans
there's really no point
yeah it's buses or I've done Amtrak
Greyhound and drive my own car yeah back
then [ __ ] yeah I couldn't afford now no
you can't fall right out as a feature
Ike there's no way you can't no
that most most of these clubs don't want
to pull up a feature nope because they
got 40 people they got 40 people in town
who can do it so now you go into a town
you gotta pay for your own hotel and you
take that difference and it's listen man
as what pisses me off is the people who
do think I do it and make money you have
to go into calmly my thinking I'm not
gonna make a dime and if I tell you what
the secret is it's the real secret that
it really is somebody told me this this
is why I know this
it's punching it yeah yeah you know
everything you do for the first ten
years you're punching it the more you
punch in the more money you'll make down
the road but you gotta keep punching it
and you can't carry that card punching
that car yep
and you know what this week's you break
even but you're working you're doing you
have to look at it that you're doing
what you didn't want to do this beats me
being blah blah this beats me being blah
blah at least I can prove to my mom that
I stayed on I made it one more fun yeah
[ __ ] yeah it's it's just this uh this
really weird feeling and that's why I
had I had my ax grind this brother and I
see that you're doing a CD and I wanna
celebrate it thank you I don't know that
people know thank you doing this
discours day at the ice house means a
lot and then you're one of the guys that
I've seen grow you're not a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you've never been a [ __ ] thanks
MA you've gone through hell you've had
management and [ __ ] stroke jobs you
know people sign you J I mean you've
gone through it all yeah and you're
still here I think someone cut there
from just taking over the world they
don't even know it so it's man I really
appreciate you coming on and I
appreciate this I really am Shane our 20
year friend off and how you know pro you
never called me complaining you've
always called with questions Oh cuz I
love your advice good advice and I hope
I'm never bothered we've always come to
a conclusion yeah I've always told you
my advice but the
make a conclusion yeah what works yep
you know if I don't have the answer I'll
call somebody who does I have heard the
situation before from somebody sure you
know I'm going I got a call from
somebody a we they want a book get a
Lorraine Oh Texas hold on one second let
me call you back
yeah what do you think of this guy don't
do it right [ __ ] Paisley way this is
what part of this business is it's
having allies that there's no animosity
between you right and me in fact I was
talking about one of the real jokes in
comedy is you you know the white people
eating Mexican food you know well the
racist uncle the races on ya thang has
always been one of my favorite but thank
you so much man and I just want people
to know he's doing the show it what time
it's to 7:30 and 9:30 listen man if you
do me have you ever did me a favor do me
this favor skids a real [ __ ] star
well I pay that this comics out there
that you know for some reason or another
Comedy Central doesn't talk to them so
you guys don't put no verification on if
you've learned anything through these
podcasts look at what you've learned
that there was a lot more comics out
there than meets the eye that you guys
never would have known about without
these stupid podcasts if you're in the
LA area Thursday night
please go down and support my main man
LaRoche er thanks [ __ ] tape a CD and
I'm Shirley you'll go up there and
applaud for you and jump up and down
you know present' the church with his
shirt on and do bombs [ __ ] yeah
did I Love You Man thank you and I gotta
tell you you you kept me going I never
told you this story but this is a
perfect one yes when I get the ever
gotten to skirt one of the nights I was
really discouraged man I think I gotten
dumped hey I'm on the road she yeah the
girl calls me and dumps me when I'm on
the road I think I might have been I was
in Tulsa I called you I was almost
crying and I was just like man I just
hope I'm doing the right thing I
remember telling you that I said I hope
I'm doing the right thing and you quoted
the beginning of Apocalypse Now and he
goes let me tell you something because
everybody out here is getting soft
because you're in the weeds getting
stronger never forget that and that kept
me going bro that was like [ __ ]
that was so I needed that I needed that
and it really it just I can't thank you
enough for that all of you remember that
night but you told me you said you're
out you [ __ ] remember that line they
says in the beginning I'm just here
getting soft Charlie's out Zoey that's
getting strong I always knew all those
years I was sacrificing yeah in a
[ __ ] bus station waiting for hours in
the middle of night you know I have
8,000 your pop you guys shop with an old
[ __ ] hot dog yeah always have at
least that going for you yeah that
you're in the bush I've been in the bush
there's people that live here right now
that are not in the bush and they've
been here for years they're not the bush
they don't know how to get in the Boyd
house and they'll never get on the bush
because they don't think that way it
also breaks your heart when you see
those dudes who were the who are the
king of the mountains in whatever town
they came from and they come out here
expecting the same thing and they can't
handle and they get that punch right I'm
talking about oh please it's it's it's I
took those fighters who have never taken
a punch and all of a sudden they're in
the ring and they're being cute and they
get whacked and they're like oh I got
punched 52 - [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah two
times and kicked oh and [ __ ] stomped
on and [ __ ] lighter and the whole
thing and you know what I'm happy I did
[ __ ] ya happy I did because hey you know
I see people and I think I was telling I
went to Cleveland with Jorge Perez and
me and George at one point we're talking
about all the people that came and went
that had more talent oh my god right I
could tell you people who came and went
that were brilliant writers or a way of
performing and they just didn't cut the
main thing with perseverance yeah they
didn't have the main thing to stick out
it was just a little perseverance and
that's it you have to wait around if you
give it enough time you wait for the
miracle to happen yeah it'll [ __ ]
happen yes and it's your own personal
miracle it may not be being louis c.k
and selling us things right now may not
be being Kevin Hart right but it's your
own [ __ ] Private Idaho and you
created it and you're happy with it and
content
and you stay within your bounds and you
don't make believe you're Joey bananas
right and you're not a premier smoking
cigar I love it I love going under the
radar
listen November 1st yup seven thirty
nine thirty at the ice house and do not
forget uncle Joey next week New York
County Festival
Gotham's Thursday sold-out Saturday late
sold-out you got three shows to [ __ ]
choose from and then the week after the
night before Thanksgiving I'm an Irvine
that's all you need to know I want to
thank Jerry LaRoche ank you man for
coming on this show my man I love it
thank you brother stay black all right I
want to thank my man Jerry Roca I want
to thank my man the [ __ ] and I
want to thank you guys for listening
don't forget the church is brought to
you by my book you let me tell you
something watching football is fun
watching sports and fun even the World
Series was tremendous but you guys heard
me talk about this for weeks and some of
yous are still waiting there we are be
aware your pockets all empty cuz you're
not making no dough don't no no don't
write me that's why whether you're an
expert or rookie you need to be betting
at my bookie if you're the kind of guy
who likes to bet a little and win a lot
like playing numbers on the roulette you
create a huge big bar lay on my bookie
you pick three teams to win all three of
them come in you could turn a hundred
dollars into six hundred dollars
you got the UFC this weekend you got
basketball you got hockey I recommend
these guys because I trust them my
bookie has been in business for years
and they've got great online reviews and
their mobile site that's where the dough
is right there it's nice and easy to use
now my bookie back by popular demand my
bookie will offer 100% bonus for one
more week this year that's right you've
been thinking about placing a pick all
season but you haven't manned up yet
this is the time to make your move after
Sunday's kickoff you could kiss that
bonus goodbye so this is the week to
sign up right now I'm not kidding you
going to bet my bookie calm right now go
to my bookie right now don't miss out on
this opportunity also make sure to
follow us on bet my bookie on Twitter or
Instagram they personally respond to
every man
and every direct meant message not to
mention they've given away nearly ten
thousand in free money to their
followers this football season so you'll
be the first to know
as soon as new odds and props are posted
now do me a favor log on to my bookie
right now and don't miss out on the last
opportunity to collect the industry's
biggest bonus use promo code Church CH
you are CH and you'll get your first
deposit matched at a hundred percent
that's right 100 percent that's right a
hundred percent that's promo code Church
CH you are CH my bookie
you play you win you get paid I love
your [ __ ] don't forget New York
City next weekend Thursday sold out all
you got is Friday and Irvine the night
before Thanksgiving with my manly side
I'll be down there with me alright have
a great Tuesday enjoy the special thank
you for supporting me without you guys I
wouldn't even have this [ __ ] thing so
thank you very much and have a great day
stay black